no I'm just gonna I'm completely numb
and I live in a luxurious world and
that's what I write about that's all I
know all I know is my own numbness and
my own luxury and the novels are a
reflection of that it's fiction you know
it's it's you know fiction in a way is I
don't know I guess it's a reflection of
I don't know your fantasies in a way I
mean I look at the books as sure on a
certain level or autobiographical but
they're also you know they're not real
my payment doesn't exist in Victor Ward
and glamour and they don't exist they're
like made up people in made-up
situations and you know that gives you
the freedom to explore your obsessions
and your fantasies and you know so and
actually I'm not a pessimistic person
i'm really not if i was a truly
pessimistic person i don't think i'd be
writing novels and i don't think i'd be
you know excited by the idea of writing
novels I mean sure if you're living in
this world you have a certain amount of
pessimism because that's just how life
is you know there's things that hit you
and oh that's in fair or oh that sucks
but in general i'm not a pessimistic
person i'm not an optimistic person by
any means but i'm not a super
pessimistic person and I'm not you know
that num i think i have a bit of a sense
of humor about things
oh it's all go to it is I arrived very
gratuitous violence and it's very um
it's all over the place I don't know I
mean I don't you know yeah there's two
books there's a lot of violence in it
there's an american psycho and there's
glamorama which are pretty violent books
and maybe they are gratuitous I don't
know I mean of course they didn't feel
gratuitous to me because I was writing
them and I felt that the violence needs
to be there but you know there's an
argument to be made sure that the
violence in american psycho is
gratuitous and I can understand that
argument I can totally get it I can get
both sides and get decide that okay look
the book is in its own way a kind of
performance art piece and the violence
needs to be there so comments on
everything else and it's all part of a
puzzle and I can also see the other side
where it just seems gross you've really
just stepped over a line here and it's
just gross and needless you know what I
think both both arguments are right I
think they're both correct it is it is
gratuitous violence and yet it can also
be seen as you know being something
that's meaningful within the context of
that book so no I mean I can see both
sides to it look I think if you're right
in novel about a serial killer or
someone who fantasizes about being a
serial killer there and you have that
kind of obsessive attention to detail
within that narrator I mean I didn't
realize how violent american psycho is
going to be until i realized what the
narrator's voice was going to be like
and that he was going to be someone
completely obsessed by consumerism and
that everything in the book was going to
be minutely detailed and then i realized
i will look I made an aesthetic choice I
said well that's going to spill into the
killings and that's how that happened
and you know if you're writing a book
about terrorists you know and you and
it's being narrated from a terrified
narrator well why is he terrified well
because of the things he's seen and so
you know a just it
it makes sense to me it doesn't seem
that I'm you know I know you're I know
you didn't mean gratuitous in a
challenging way but um no I don't feel
that the books are gratuitously violent
oh yes i do i don't know maybe they are
it's not I don't know it's for an
audience to decide let's take a vote
gratuitous not gratuitous